in this video we're going to talk about
the greenhouse
effect and also the greenhouse gases
which cause the greenhouse effect
now let's just start with a basic idea
imagine if earth had no atmosphere what
would happen well you have the sun which
is on average 93 million miles away it's
sending electromagnetic radiation our
way to the surface of the earth we're
actually getting a very very small
fraction of the total electromagnetic
radiation of the sun and then that would
heat up the surface of the earth
now what i have always found
mind-blowing is anything with
temperature will emit electromagnetic
radiation and so it's emitting some of
that energy it's losing some of that
energy to electromagnetic radiation so
the surface would be releasing that and
it would go out into space
but now let's introduce the idea of an
atmosphere and in particular we're going
to think about our lower atmosphere
which starts at the surface and goes up
to about five to nine miles in altitude
often known as the troposphere
now the troposphere has molecules in it
has gases in it like carbon dioxide like
water vapor like methane others include
nitrous oxide and chlorophyll carbons
you don't have to know the chemical
formula of all of these things but
what's interesting about these gases
that are in the lower atmosphere is that
they can absorb some of those
electromagnetic waves that the surface
of the earth is emitting so some of that
energy will make it out to space but
some of that energy will then be
absorbed by these molecules by these
gases and that they will emit some of
that back to earth and so that's why
it's called a greenhouse effect because
of all of that energy that might have
been sent out to space if you didn't
have an atmosphere
not all of it is some of it is
reabsorbed by the atmosphere which then
sends it back down to the surface and
that process can go on and on and on you
can imagine that it's trapping some of
the energy
now the greenhouse effect and greenhouse
gases the ones that i just listed
they're oftentimes associated with
man-made climate change and global
warming and they are for good reason but
it's important to realize that we
actually need some base level greenhouse
effect
just for earth to be habitable in the
way that it is
without greenhouse gases earth's surface
would be about negative 18 degrees
celsius which is the same as zero
degrees fahrenheit which i think most of
y'all would recognize is very very very
cold
relative to what the actual averages are
which are 15 degrees celsius or 59
degrees fahrenheit and of course these
are average temperatures but 59 is a
nice refreshing brisk day not a frigid
day like zero degrees fahrenheit and of
course these are averages it fluctuates
around this depending on time of year
and where you are but this makes it
clear that we do need these greenhouse
gases to keep the earth reasonably warm
now the problem is is if the
concentration of these greenhouse gases
go out of equilibrium become unusually
high
and it does look like that is indeed
happening
this right over here is a chart and the
way that we're able to figure that out
is by taking ice samples and rock
samples and looking into our past
through the geological record of how
much carbon dioxide there has been over
the last 800 thousand years and eight
hundred thousand years is a very long
time period modern human beings have
only been around for two or three
hundred thousand years and what you can
see is the concentration of carbon
dioxide has roughly fluctuated between
about 200 parts per million and about
300 parts per million at least over the
duration of this chart but in recent
times we've gone well beyond that we've
almost gone double that average right
over here and this is actually the
highest levels we've seen
in 3 million years
now it's important to realize that
carbon dioxide makes up a small
percentage of our atmosphere in fact all
of these greenhouse gases make up a
small percentage 78 percent of the
troposphere is nitrogen 21 is oxygen the
last one percent
is things like argon water vapor carbon
dioxide methane so even this small
amount when the concentration increases
dramatically can have a huge effect now
you might say hey we were at these these
levels three million years ago roughly
maybe this is just some type of cycle
that we're seeing on earth and to
recognize that this is indeed man-made
we just have to look at a chart like
this this tells us two things this tells
us annual emissions in this blue line
this blue curve and then the total
emission or the total concentration in
the atmosphere because one other thing
about one of the things about a
greenhouse gas like carbon dioxide when
it's emitted it doesn't just disappear
and we can see if we go to the
pre-industrial revolution or the early
stages of the industrial revolution co2
emissions were pretty low pretty close
to zero at least on this scale right
over here there might have been some
basic co2 emissions people had fires and
stoves and things like that but then as
the industrial revolution came into play
and we started using fossil fuels more
and more to fuel transportation and
factories and other things our emissions
have gone up dramatically and this
coincides with the total concentration
going well above that 800 000 year
average so it's important to keep in
mind the greenhouse effect is needed to
some degree but the problem is is when
the concentration of greenhouse gases
like carbon dioxide go well beyond their
historic averages which can over time
warm the earth and even a few degrees
centigrade of warming the earth can have
huge consequences on our environment and
on our weather i'll throw out one last
idea just for kicks because even though
it's called the greenhouse effect it's
actually not how actual greenhouses work
the greenhouse effect as we just
described it is really based on this
idea that things are getting the
infrared radiation the electromagnetic
radiation is getting reabsorbed which
then gets re-emitted back to the surface
and vice versa in a real greenhouse you
can imagine that it is made out of glass
what's happening is
the sunlight can come in and it's
warming the surface and it's warming the
air inside the greenhouse and then that
air is not allowed to circulate so if
the if the greenhouse had a little hole
at the top right over here that hot air
would be allowed to go out and circulate
with the cool air up here but the air
isn't allowed to mix and so the air gets
hotter and hotter and hotter it actually
turns out that the glass can let the
electromagnetic radiation out unlike
greenhouse gases so it is a different
actual physical process but you can see
where people tried to create the
metaphor